on revient montréal un accident
extrêmement rare est survenu très tôt ce
matin sur le pont jacques cartier
une collision entre deux cyclistes l'un
est mort l'autre a été grièvement
blessée je rejoins jacques bissonnet
jacques qu'est ce que c'est pas assez
écoutée on connaît très peu de choses
sur les circonstances exactes de
l'accident
la sûreté du québec qui est responsable
de la sécurité ici sur le pont et se
borne à dire qu'il s'agit d'une
collision entre deux cyclistes un peu
avant 4 heures du matin qui a fait un
mort donc il s'agit de christian
d'haguenau 55 ans de montréal et un
blessé grave une jeune femme de 24 ans
de longueuil
maintenant les policiers confirment
également que les deux sites lice ne
portait pas de casque
on a aussi appris que les bandes vidéo
donc des caméras de surveillance du pont
ont été saisis par la sûreté du québec
et analysées aujourd'hui
évidemment ici patricia beaucoup de
cyclistes qui empruntent cette piste
cyclable et plusieurs nous ont dit que
c'était une pièce assez dangereuse très
de chalandise certains moments de la
journée
en voici un d'ailleurs qui a passé sur
les lieux de l'accident
quelques minutes seulement après le
drame je pensais ce matin j'ai vu le
malheureusement le cac est à l'heure
puis ça le poteau que c'était mais
encore
mais attends à l'heure de pointe à pau
sécurité du tout les gens quand même des
chiens et des pachas roues et des spots
aux lettrés qui a des poux certes des
touristes prendre des photos lieu de
tout sur cette piste laissent les gens
aient un peu de lumière
ils sont pas visés alors ça se peut que
l'accident soit la cause de l'accident
ce soir on va le voir jacques avec le
visuel qu'on a tourné
c'est une piste cyclable quand même
assez étroites et si on ne voit pas bien
il ya de la brume c'est loeb ça peut
expliquer donc ce qui est arrivé oui
tout à fait écouter mais c'est une piste
cyclabe cependant patrice qui est
réglementaire qui à deux mètres de large
donc ça va mais il ya des courbes et ici
les gens vont vite mettant propos
l'assurance automobile
c'est important de signaler patrice
parce que il n'y a aura pas d
démonisation pourquoi parce qu'il ya pas
de véhicules moteurs n'y a pas de d'auto
d'impliquer dans l'accident c'est un
accident de la route mais ici ce
rond-point est denise et d'ailleurs
cette situation est dénoncée par
l'organisme vélo québec comme le précise
sa présidente l'excusent devrait couvrir
couverts par ce régime là vont sûrement
que la majorité des cyclistes adultes
ont un permis de conduire donc peu leurs
faibles leurs frais pour obtenir la cami
conduire à une situation peu
anachronique certains trous on appelle
ça un trou dans la loi
alors patrice ou s'il va y en a près
qu'il va y avoir une enquête du coroner
sur cet accident
maintenant il ya eu un autre site risque
et perdu la vie sur la rue saint denis
samedi soir et on appris aujourd'hui de
la police que c'est le conducteur de
l'automobile qui a ouvert sa portière au
moment où le cycliste passait il a été
tué sur le coup alors prudence un vélo
merci jacques